Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂运营产生了显著的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在通往净零排放的道路上大步迈进。投资于技术和创新。每桶碳排放平均已经减少了22%。与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位。开发世界上最大的碳捕获和储存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，并且我们在多个途径上都取得了进展。请在 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On the morning of Wednesday, February 8, 2006, Wyoming resident Bonnie Burns sat by her telephone, willing it to ring. Minutes ticked by, but the phone remained silent. With each passing moment, Bonnie's growing sense of unease increased further. She was waiting for a call from her daughter, 41-year-old Tammy Rhea, who lived interstate in the small South Dakota city of Peer. Every single morning without fail, Tammy would call Bonnie for an early catch up.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获得保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。2006年2月8日星期三清晨，怀俄明州居民邦妮·伯恩斯（Bonnie Burns）坐在电话机旁，祈祷着它能响起来。分分秒秒过去，但电话依然毫无声息。随着时间的推移，邦妮内心的不安感进一步加剧。她一直在等她41岁的女儿塔米·里亚（Tammy Rhea）的电话，塔米住在跨州的南达科他州小城市皮尔。每天清晨，塔米都会雷打不动地给邦妮打电话进行早间问候。
Sometimes the calls were brief, other times they were long, but not a morning went by without one. This was the first morning that Tammy hadn't called. Unable to contain her concern any longer, Bonnie picked up the receiver and dialed Tammy's home number. She sat listening as the call rang out with no answer. Bonnie hung up and tried Tammy's cell phone. This time the call went to voicemail. Bonnie informed her husband and other two daughters that she was unable to get a hold of Tammy, and they too began taking turns trying to reach her. But, no matter how many times they tried, every single call went unanswered.
有时电话很短，有时则很长，但没有一个早晨不打电话的。这是塔米第一次没有打电话的早晨。邦妮再也无法按捺心中的担忧，拿起话筒拨通了塔米家里的电话。她坐在那儿听着电话铃响却没有回应。邦妮挂断电话，又拨了塔米的手机。这次电话转入了语音信箱。邦妮告诉她的丈夫和另外两个女儿，她联系不上塔米，于是他们也轮流试着联系她。但是，无论他们尝试了多少次，每一个电话都无人接听。
There was a one-hour time difference between Bonnie's home in Lander, Wyoming, and Tammy's home in Peer, South Dakota. When Bonnie realized it was almost 9am where Tammy lived, she decided to try her daughter at work. Tammy was employed part-time in the shoe department of a Kmart store. Bonnie soon got a hold of one of Tammy's colleagues who paged Tammy over the store's loudspeaker system. Bonnie listened closely as her daughter's name echoed throughout the store, but there was no response. Tammy wasn't there. Bonnie's concerns swelled into panic. There were approximately 550 miles between her and Tammy, and she had no way of searching for her daughter from such a distance.
邦妮在怀俄明州兰德的家与塔米在南达科他州皮尔的家之间有一个小时的时差。当邦妮意识到塔米住的地方快到早上9点时，她决定去女儿的工作单位找她。塔米在凯马特（Kmart）百货商店的鞋类部门兼职。邦妮很快联系上了塔米的一位同事，这位同事通过商店的广播系统寻呼了塔米。邦妮仔细听着女儿的名字在整个商店回荡，但没有任何回应。塔米不在那儿。邦妮的担忧升级成了恐慌。她和塔米之间大约相距550英里，她无法在这么远的距离外寻找女儿。
Wondering what to do next, Bonnie suddenly remembered the name of one of Tammy's work colleagues, Brian Clark. Tammy had recently told her mother that she and Brian had become good friends, so Bonnie thought he might have some insight as to where Tammy might be. Bonnie dialed the Kmart's phone number again, this time asking if there was a Brian there. Brian Clark had just started his shift when Bonnie's call came through. He picked up the phone and listened as Bonnie introduced herself and asked if he knew where Tammy was. Brian said that he didn't. He had last seen Tammy at about 5 o'clock the previous afternoon. However, he did offer one new piece of information.
邦妮正想着下一步该做什么，突然想起了塔米的一个同事的名字——布莱恩·克拉克（Brian Clark）。塔米最近曾告诉她母亲，她和布莱恩成了好朋友，所以邦妮认为他对塔米可能在哪里会有所了解。邦妮再次拨通了凯马特的电话号码，这次询问有没有一个叫布莱恩的人。邦妮的电话打进来时，布莱恩·克拉克刚刚开始上班。他接起电话，听着邦妮做自我介绍并询问他是否知道塔米在哪里。布莱恩说他不知道。他最后一次见到塔米是在前一天下午5点左右。不过，他确实提供了一条新的信息。
Tammy was supposed to be starting a new job at a nearby pharmacy that day. Brian offered to call the pharmacy to see if Tammy had arrived. Bonnie gratefully accepted and waited eagerly for the phone to ring. Within a few minutes, he called back, but not with the news Bonnie wanted to hear. There was no sign of Tammy at the pharmacy either. Bonnie's anxiety peaked. She decided it was time to call the police. Brian offered to make the call himself.
塔米那天本该在附近的一家药房开始一份新工作。布莱恩主动提出给药房打电话，看看塔米是否已经到了。邦妮感激地接受了，并急切地等待着电话响起。几分钟内，他回了电话，但传来的并不是邦妮想听到的消息。药房也没有塔米的踪迹。邦妮的焦虑达到了顶峰。她决定是时候报警了。布莱恩主动提出由他来打这个电话。
He hung up, then dialed 911. When the operator answered, Brian told them he needed to file a missing persons report. He gave them a brief description of what Tammy was wearing the previous afternoon. A black turtleneck. He then added, Foul play could be suspected here. The operator asked Brian why he would think such a thing. Brian answered,
他挂了电话，然后拨打911。接线员接听后，布莱恩告诉他们他需要报案失踪人员。他简要描述了塔米前一天下午穿的衣服。一件黑色高领毛衣。接着他补充道，这里可能存在谋杀犯罪嫌疑。接线员问布莱恩为什么会这么想。布莱恩回答，
Hopefully this is discreet, but me and her have been having an affair and apparently her husband has found out about it. Earlier that morning, when 12-year-old Hayley Rhea sat down to eat breakfast, something was off. Her father Brad Rhea was milling about, but her mother Tammy was nowhere to be seen. Tammy was usually bustling about in the kitchen and preparing for the day ahead, but on this particular morning, the house was strangely quiet. Hayley headed to her mother's bedroom. The bed was unmade and Tammy's cell phone was on the dresser, but Tammy wasn't there.
希望这件事能保密，但我和她一直在偷情，显然她丈夫已经发现了。那天清晨，当12岁的海莉·里亚（Hayley Rhea）坐下来吃早餐时，感觉有点不对劲。她的父亲布拉德·里亚（Brad Rhea）在附近踱来踱去，但她的母亲塔米却不见踪影。塔米通常会在厨房里忙进忙出，为新的一天做准备，但在这个特定的早晨，家里出奇地安静。海莉走向母亲的卧室。床没有整理，塔米的手机放在梳妆台上，但塔米不在那里。
Hayley went into the garage and saw that her mother's car was still parked there. Confused, she walked back into the kitchen. She noticed that Tammy's purse and keys were sitting on the counter. Hayley wasn't sure what was happening. Her mother was always home in the morning and it made no sense that she'd be out without her car, purse, phone or keys. The two had spent the previous evening together while Brad had been working late. It had been a normal, uneventful evening. Tammy had watched Hayley play volleyball at her middle school, then they'd gone grocery shopping and grabbed some Mexican takeaway for dinner.
海莉走进车库，看到母亲的车还停在那里。她感到困惑，又走回厨房。她注意到塔米的钱包和钥匙正放在柜台上。海莉不确定发生了什么。她的母亲早上总是在家，没开车、没钱包、没手机也没钥匙就出门是说不通的。前一天晚上，在布拉德加班的时候，母女俩一直在一起。那是一个普通而平静的夜晚。塔米看了海莉在中学进行的排球比赛，然后她们去买杂货，并买了一些墨西哥外卖作为晚餐。
At no point did Tammy mention anything about going anywhere the next day. Baffled as to where her mother might be, Hayley asked her father what was going on. In a quiet voice, Brad replied, Honey, she's probably at her boyfriend's house. She'll be back in a couple of days. Tammy Burns had met her future husband, Brad Rhea, when she was a 27-year-old living in Billings, Montana. The pair had been introduced by Tammy's sister, who worked alongside Brad at a restaurant. Tammy and Brad immediately hit it off and within a year, Tammy was pregnant. She couldn't have been happier. It had been her dream to get married and have a daughter.
塔米在任何时候都没有提到第二天要出门的任何事情。对于母亲可能在哪里感到迷惑不解，海莉问父亲发生了什么事。布拉德用平静的声音回答，亲爱的，她可能在她男朋友家。过几天她就会回来的。塔米·伯恩斯27岁住在蒙大拿州比林斯时，遇到了她未来的丈夫布拉德·里亚。两人是由塔米的姐姐介绍认识的，姐姐和布拉德在一家餐馆一起工作。塔米和布拉德一拍即合，不到一年，塔米就怀孕了。她高兴极了。结婚并生一个女儿一直是她的梦想。
Tammy and Brad tied the knot and she gave birth to a beautiful baby girl they named Hayley. Tammy absolutely adored being a mother. She thrived in the role, taking care of Hayley and the home while Brad focused on building his career. He got a job at Walmart and slowly climbed his way up the ranks. Although he was busy, he always made time for Tammy and Hayley. In 2004, Brad's hard work paid off. He was offered a promotion to assistant manager, but it required the family to relocate interstate to Peer. Although Peer was the capital of South Dakota, it was home to less than 14,000 people and there wasn't a lot of action. Its biggest attraction was the O'Wahee Dam and its adjoining lake, which was a hotspot for fishing and hunting.
塔米和布拉德结了婚，她生下一个漂亮的女婴，他们给她取名叫海莉。塔米非常喜爱当母亲。她在角色中游刃有余，照顾海莉和家，而布拉德则专注于建立自己的事业。他在沃尔玛找到了一份工作，并慢慢向上晋升。尽管他很忙，但他总是抽出时间陪伴海莉和塔米.2004年，布拉德的努力得到了回报。他获得了晋升为助理经理的机会，但这需要全家跨州搬迁到皮尔。尽管皮尔是南达科他州的首都，但那里的人口不到1万4千人，没有什么太多的活动。它最大的景点是奥瓦希大坝及其毗邻的湖泊，那是钓鱼和打猎的热门地点。
Regardless, Peer offered a scenic and safe place to raise a family, so Brad accepted the promotion. The news wasn't well received by Hayley, who didn't want to leave her school and friends. Tammy's feelings were mixed. She wanted to support her husband's career, but was reluctant to leave her life in billings behind. Regardless, the move went ahead and within a few months of the Rhea family's arrival in Peer, things started looking up. Hayley joined several sporting teams, which opened the doors for her and Tammy to meet new people. Things improved further when Tammy applied for a part-time job at Kmart. It was there that she met Brian Clark. When Hayley couldn't find Tammy on the morning of Wednesday, February 8, 2006, she was shocked when Brad said she was likely at her boyfriend's house.
无论如何，皮尔为抚养家庭提供了一个风景优美且安全的地方，因此布拉德接受了晋升。这个消息并没有受到海莉的欢迎，她不想离开学校和朋友。塔米的心情很复杂。她想支持丈夫的事业，但不愿抛下她在比林斯的生活。无论如何，搬迁还是进行了，在里亚一家抵达皮尔几个月后，情况开始好转。海莉加入了几个运动队，这为她和塔米结识新朋友打开了大门。当塔米申请在凯马特做兼职工作时，情况进一步改善。正是在那里，她遇到了布莱恩·克拉克。当海莉在2006年2月8日星期三清晨找不到塔米时，当布拉德说她可能在她男朋友家时，她惊呆了。
This was the first Hayley had heard about her mother having a boyfriend, although she was aware that her parents' relationship was in trouble. Two weeks earlier, Brad and Tammy had sat her down to break the news that they were getting a divorce. Brad had been working incredibly long shifts, sometimes up to 100 hours a week, and had taken a toll on their marriage. Brad and Tammy assured their daughter that everything was going to be okay, and they would do their best to ensure things didn't change too much. The couple planned on staying together until the end of the school year, so that the transition didn't impact Hayley's education. Brad would then move out, while Tammy and Hayley continued living in the family home. Tammy had already found a full-time job doing Medicare billing for a local pharmacy, so she could provide as a single mother. The news of the divorce caught Hayley completely off guard.
这是海莉第一次听说母亲有男朋友，尽管她知道父母的关系出了问题。两周前，布拉德和塔米让她坐下来，向她宣布他们要离婚的消息。布拉德的工作时间长得惊人，有时甚至每周工作100个小时，这对他们的婚姻造成了沉重的打击。布拉德和塔米向女儿保证一切都会好起来的，他们会尽最大努力确保事情不会发生太大的变化。这对夫妇计划一直生活到学年结束，这样过渡就不会影响海莉的教育。然后布拉德会搬出去，而塔米和海莉继续住在家里。塔米已经找到了一份为当地药房做医疗保险结算的全职工作，这样她就可以作为单亲妈妈养家糊口。离婚的消息让海莉完全措手不及。
Her parents never fought, and she had no reason to believe that a divorce was on the horizon. She was devastated. With Brad now revealing that Tammy had a boyfriend, Hayley didn't know what to think. Why hadn't her mother mentioned anything? The two were incredibly close, and shared similar personality traits. Tammy was a strong athlete who'd earned a volleyball scholarship as a teenager. Hayley had inherited her mother's love of sports, as well as her fun and outgoing manner. The two had never kept secrets from one another before.
她的父母从不吵架，她也没有理由相信离婚即将来临。她崩溃了。随着布拉德现在透露塔米有男朋友，海莉不知道该怎么想。为什么她母亲没有提过任何事？两人关系极其亲密，有着相似的性格特征。塔米是一名出色的运动员，在十几岁时就赢得了排球奖学金。海莉继承了母亲对运动的热爱，以及她有趣和外向的性格。两人以前从未对彼此保守过秘密。
Hayley continued getting ready for school, but all she could think about was her mother. After dropping Hayley off at school, Brad Rea made his way to work. He hadn't been there long when two detectives suddenly entered the building and asked to speak with him. They had received the missing person report from Brian Clarke and hoped that Brad might have information about Tammy's whereabouts. When Brad heard that Tammy hadn't shown up for work and police suspected she was missing, he was visibly shocked. He explained that he hadn't seen Tammy since the day before. Brad had arrived home from work just after 10pm to find Hayley asleep in bed, but strangely, Tammy wasn't at home. Several hours passed with no sign of her.
海莉继续准备去学校，但她脑子里想的全是母亲。把海莉送到学校后，布拉德·里亚前往上班。他去没多久，两名侦探突然走进大楼，要求与他谈话。他们收到了来自布莱恩·克拉克的失踪人员报告，并希望布拉德能提供关于塔米下落的信息。当布拉德听说塔米没有去上班且警方怀疑她失踪时，他显得非常震惊。他解释说，他自前一天起就没见过塔米。布拉德晚上10点多下班回家，发现海莉在床上睡觉，但奇怪的是，塔米不在家。几个小时过去了，依然不见她的踪影。
Then, at around 1am, Brad heard a car pull up outside. He peered through a window and saw Tammy park her car, a black Dodge Durango SUV. Another car then pulled up behind her and Tammy got out of her Durango and into the other vehicle. Brad had recently learned that Tammy was seeing another man, so he assumed that's who the other car belonged to. Acting on impulse, he hopped into Tammy's Durango and attempted to follow them. However, after driving a short distance, the Durango broke down and Brad had to pull over to the side of the road. A passing highway patrol officer noticed him and pulled over to provide assistance. By the time Brad got the car started again, he'd long lost sight of Tammy, so he drove back home and went to bed.
然后，大约凌晨1点，布拉德听到一辆车在外面停下。他透过窗户向外张望，看到塔米把她的车——一辆黑色道奇杜兰戈（Dodge Durango）SUV停好。接着另一辆车停在她后面，塔米从她的杜兰戈车上下来，坐进了另一辆车里。布拉德最近得知塔米在跟另一个男人交往，所以他认为另一辆车就是那个男人的。出于冲动，他跳进塔米的杜兰戈车，试图尾随他们。然而，开了一小段路后，杜兰戈车抛锚了，布拉德不得不把车停在路边。一名路过的公路巡警注意到了他，并靠边停车提供协助。等布拉德重新发动汽车时，他早已失去了塔米的踪影，于是他开车回家上床睡觉了。
When he woke in the morning to find Tammy still wasn't at home, he just assumed she had taken off with her boyfriend and would be home in a couple of days. The detectives listened attentively to Brad's account of the previous night's events. At just 5'7 and 115 pounds, he didn't look like a dangerous man, and there was nothing in his demeanor to suggest he was lying. The detectives asked whether it was possible that Tammy had since returned to the family home. Perhaps she'd decided to pack some belongings, knowing her husband was at work. Brad offered to escort them to the house in case Tammy was there. What he didn't know was that the detectives had already stopped off at his home before going to visit him at work. One of them had peered through the garage window and noticed something that caught his eye.
当他在早晨醒来发现塔米依然不在家时，他只是以为她和男朋友私奔了，过几天就会回家。侦探们认真聆听了布拉德对前一晚事件的叙述。身高只有5尺7寸、体重115磅的他看起来不像是个危险人物，而且他的举止中也没有任何迹象表明他在撒谎。侦探们询问塔米是否有可能在此期间已经返回了家中。也许她知道丈夫在上班，决定收拾一些随身物品。布拉德主动提出陪同他们去房子里，以防塔米在那里。他不知道的是，侦探们在去单位找他之前，其实已经先去过他家了。其中一人曾透过车库窗户向里看，注意到了一些吸引他目光的东西。
Brad and the detectives drove to the residence where Brad signed a form consenting to a search of the property. He waited outside while one detective entered to look for Tammy and the other went to search her vehicle. Upon entering the garage, the detectives saw a reddish-brown stain on the door of Tammy's Durango. This is what he'd noticed earlier when looking through the window and had suspected it was blood. As he moved closer, he also saw what appeared to be blood dripping from the vehicle's side running board. Each drop fell in a small pool on the concrete floor below at a rate that indicated someone had lost a significant amount of blood. The detective opened the Durango's back door and was overwhelmed by the strong stench of bleach. He noticed swirls on the vehicle's upholstery that suggested someone had tried to wipe something up.
布拉德和侦探们开车来到住所，布拉德在表单上签字同意对房产进行搜查。他在外面等候，而一名侦探进去寻找塔米，另一名去搜查她的车。一进入车库，侦探就看到塔米杜兰戈车门上有红褐色的污渍。这就是他之前透过窗户看时注意到并怀疑是血迹的东西。当他走近时，他还看到似乎有血迹从车辆的侧踏板上滴落下来。每一滴都落在了下方混凝土地面上的一个小血泊中，其速度表明有人流了大量的血。侦探打开杜兰戈的后门，被强烈的漂白剂气味熏得喘不过气来。他注意到车内装饰上有漩涡状的擦痕，这表明有人曾试图擦拭掉什么。
Everything about the situation suggested foul play, but the detective didn't want to alert Brad to what he'd found. Brad could withdraw his consent for the search at any time, and the detective wanted to secure an official search warrant before the homeowner changed his mind. Instead, the two detectives asked Brad to join them at the station to answer some questions. While he was away from home, they would covertly apply for a search warrant. Meanwhile, Haley was sitting in class worrying about her mother when a message suddenly blared over the loudspeaker summoning her to the front office. Haley's mind started to race. She nervously walked to the office and was greeted by a police officer who wanted to ask her some questions about her parents' relationship. Haley said that her mom and dad didn't fight and there had never been any violence between them.
情况的一切都表明发生了谋杀犯罪，但侦探不想惊动布拉德让他知道自己发现了什么。布拉德随时可以撤回对搜查的同意，侦探希望在房主改变主意之前获得一份正式的搜查令。相反，这两名侦探要求布拉德和他们一起去警局回答一些问题。在他离开家期间，他们将秘密申请搜查令。与此同时，海莉坐在教室里为母亲担心，这时扩音器里突然传出一个声音，命令她去前台办公室。海莉的心思开始飞转。她紧张地走向办公室，迎面走来一名警察，想问她一些关于父母关系的问题。海莉说她的爸爸妈妈不吵架，他们之间从来没有过任何暴力。
Because of this, the recent news of their divorce had been very unexpected. When she had gone to bed the night before, Tammy was at home and nothing seemed out of the ordinary. While Haley was being questioned, police contacted some of Tammy's friends and family to see if they knew where Tammy could be. There was a reason why Tammy's mother hadn't contacted Brad when Tammy missed their early morning phone call. During the recent Christmas break, Tammy had visited her family in Wyoming and told them she planned on leaving her husband. Tammy's family suspected she might have been seeing someone else as she had mentioned Brian's name several times, but they had impressed her on the matter. Brad had even called Tammy's mother Bonnie asking for her help to save their marriage, but it was clear that Tammy had already made up her mind. Back at the peer police station, Brad was cooperative as detectives sat him down for a chat.
正因为如此，最近传出他们离婚的消息非常出乎意料。前一天晚上她睡觉时，塔米在家，一切看起来都很正常。在对海莉进行盘问的同时，警方联系了塔米的一些朋友和家人，看他们是否知道塔米会在哪里。塔米没有在清晨错过电话时联系布拉德是有原因的。在最近的圣诞假期期间，塔米曾去怀俄明州探望家人，并告诉他们她计划离开丈夫。塔米的家人怀疑她可能在和别人交往，因为她多次提到布莱恩的名字，但他们没有在这个问题上逼问她。布拉德甚至给塔米的母亲邦妮打电话寻求她的帮助以挽救他们的婚姻，但很明显塔米已经下定决心了。回到皮尔警察局，当侦探们让布拉德坐下来谈话时，他非常配合。
He told them that Tammy had recently revealed she was dating another man and wanted a divorce, but Brad didn't know who the other man was or where he lived. He said that he didn't want to know and wasn't curious to find out. Brad strongly denied having anything to do with Tammy's disappearance and insisted he had no idea where she could be. When the detectives told Brad that blood had been found on the running board of Tammy's Durango, he was visibly shocked. He admitted he was the last person to drive the vehicle when attempting to trail Tammy the night before, repeating his story about breaking down and a highway patrol officer offering assistance. Brad insisted that after restarting the car, he drove straight home. He didn't recall hitting an animal or anything else.
他告诉他们，塔米最近透露她正在和另一个男人约会并想要离婚，但布拉德不知道另一个男人是谁，也不知道他住在哪里。他说他不想知道，也没有好奇去查明。布拉德强烈否认自己与塔米的失踪有任何关系，并坚信自己不知道她会在哪里。当侦探们告诉布拉德在塔米的杜兰戈车的踏板上发现了血迹时，他明显感到震惊。他承认自己在前一天晚上试图尾随塔米时是最后一个驾驶该车的人，并重复了他关于车子抛锚以及公路巡警提供协助的说法。布拉德坚信重新启动汽车后，他直接开车回了家。他不记得撞过动物或其他任何东西。
When he got home, he parked the Durango in the garage. If Tammy or anyone else had returned to retrieve the vehicle, he didn't know about it. While Brad was questioned, the search warrant for his house was approved. Police examined each room, but nothing appeared to be out of place. The beds were all made and the washer and dryer were filled with clean laundry. There was no sign of Tammy and no indication that anything untoward had happened. Other than the blood in Tammy's vehicle, it appeared to be a warm and loving family home. Yet, when investigators swabbed the Durango for forensic evidence,
他回到家时，把杜兰戈车停在了车库里。如果塔米或其他任何人回来取过车，他并不知道。在对布拉德进行盘问的同时，对他家的搜查令也获批了。警方检查了每一个房间，但没有发现任何异常。床都铺好了，洗衣机和烘干机里装满了干净的衣物。没有塔米的踪迹，也没有任何迹象表明发生过什么不寻常的事情。除了塔米车上的血迹之外，这看起来像是一个温馨而充满爱的家庭。然而，当调查人员用棉签擦拭杜兰戈以获取法医证据时，
they realized that there was much more blood than they initially thought. Samples were sent to a forensic lab along with some of Tammy's personal belongings to confirm whether it was a match for her DNA. The interviewing detectives were at a loss. Brad didn't have a criminal record and there was no evidence to suggest he was responsible for Tammy's disappearance. However, the amount of blood found in her car indicated she had been seriously harmed and most likely killed. If this was the case, Brad was the most likely suspect. He had access to Tammy's car and her desire for a divorce suggested an obvious motive.
他们意识到血迹比他们最初想象的要多得多。样本被送到法医实验室，连同塔米的一些个人物品一起，以确认是否与她的DNA相匹配。负责问话的侦探们一筹莫展。布拉德没有犯罪前科，也没有证据表明他对塔米的失踪负有责任。然而，在她车里发现的血迹量表明她受到了严重的伤害，并且极有可能是被杀害了。如果是这样的话，布拉德是最有可能的嫌疑人。他有接触塔米汽车的途径，而她想要离婚则提供了一个明显的动机。
The problem was, without a body, they couldn't even be certain that Tammy was dead. Brad was interrogated for five hours, with detectives slowly increasing the pressure. Despite their persistent questioning, Brad continued to deny having any knowledge of Tammy's whereabouts. Desperate for answers, the detectives flatly accused him of lying. This accusation was the final straw for Brad. He asked for a lawyer. Now, the detectives were faced with a difficult decision. They still couldn't be 100% certain that Tammy was dead, but all signs pointed to homicide. If Brad was responsible and they let him go, it would give him an opportunity to destroy any potential evidence.
问题在于，没有尸体，他们甚至无法确定塔米已经死了。布拉德被审讯了五个小时，侦探们的压力步步升级。尽管他们坚持不懈地盘问，布拉德仍然否认自己知道塔米的下落。迫切想要答案的侦探们直截了当地指责他在撒谎。这个指责成了压垮布拉德的最后一根稻草。他要求请律师。现在，侦探们面临着一个艰难的决定。他们仍然无法百分之百确定塔米已经死了，但所有的迹象都指向谋杀。如果布拉德是罪魁祸首而他们放了他，这会给他销毁任何潜在证据的机会。
Under pressure to make a call, they abruptly arrested Brad for first-degree murder, setting bail at $100,000. Brad was incredulous and staunchly maintained his innocence. Haley was placed in foster care overnight as Tammy's family in Wyoming were brought up to speed with what was going on. Unable to bear the thought of Haley being on her own, Tammy's father got in his car and began the nearly nine-hour drive to be with his granddaughter. Brad's friends were stunned to learn he'd been arrested for murder. Brad was a gentle family man, and they couldn't imagine him ever raising a hand to his wife, let alone launching a vicious and deadly attack. However, they weren't surprised to hear that he hadn't pushed Tammy for information about the other man she was seeing. Brad was a mild-mannered person, hounding Tammy wouldn't be in his nature.
在做出决定的压力下，他们突然以一级谋杀罪逮捕了布拉德，保释金定为10万美元。布拉德难以置信，坚决坚称自己是无辜的。海莉连夜被送入寄养家庭，而塔米在怀俄明州的家人则被告知了所发生的事情。无法忍受海莉独自一人呆着的想法，塔米的父亲上了车，开始了近九个小时的驾车行程去陪伴他的外孙女。布拉德的朋友们得知他因谋杀被捕时都惊呆了。布拉德是一个温和顾家的好男人，他们无法想象他会对妻子动一根手指，更不用说发动残酷致命的攻击了。然而，听到他没有向塔米追问她所交往的另一个男人的信息，他们并不感到惊讶。布拉德是一个温和的人，纠缠塔米不是他的天性。
With Brad in custody, the next step for detectives was to question Tammy's boyfriend, Brian Clark. He was summoned to the police station and arrived with a lawyer by his side. Like Tammy, Brian was also married with a daughter. The two co-workers had initially hit it off as friends, but their friendship had slowly become physical and blossomed into a romance. Brian told detectives the last time he saw Tammy was on the afternoon of Tuesday, February 7, the day before she went missing. The two had met at the Fawn Motel in Peer. Afterwards, Brian dropped Tammy home at around 5pm. From there, he attended a local basketball game with his wife and daughter.
随着布拉德被拘留，侦探们的下一步是审问塔米的男友布莱恩·克拉克。他被传唤到警察局，在律师的陪同下到达。和塔米一样，布莱恩也已结婚并育有一个女儿。这两个同事最初作为朋友一拍即合，但他们的友谊慢慢发展成肉体关系并绽放为浪漫恋情。布莱恩告诉侦探，他最后一次见到塔米是在2月7日星期二下午，也就是她失踪前一天。两人在皮尔的法恩汽车旅馆（Fawn Motel）见了面。之后，布莱恩在大约下午5点把塔米送回家。从那里，他和妻子女儿一起去观看当地的一场篮球比赛。
When the game finished, he went home with his family and didn't leave the house again until going to work the next morning. Brian said his wife could verify his alibi. The only problem was that she didn't know about his affair with Tammy and he didn't want her to know. He was reluctant for police to question her as there would be no way to do so without revealing this information. Once again, the detectives weren't sure what to think. Brian seemed genuine, but the fact that he'd already retained and brought a lawyer with him seemed suspicious. If he was innocent, why did he feel compelled to seek legal counsel from the get-go? The fact that Brian's wife didn't know about his affair with Tammy also gave Brian a strong motive for murder.
比赛结束后，他和家人一起回家，直到第二天早上上班才再次出门。布赖恩说他的妻子可以为他的不在场证明作证。唯一的问题是，她并不知道他和塔米有染，而他也不想让她知道。他不愿让警察盘问她，因为这样做势必会暴露这一秘密。侦探们再次陷入了迷茫，不知该作何感想。布赖恩看起来很真诚，但他已经请了律师并将其带在身边的这一事实却显得十分可疑。如果他是清白的，为什么从一开始就觉得有必要寻求法律顾问呢？布赖恩的妻子对他和塔米的私情一无所知这一事实，也让布赖恩多了一个重大的谋杀动机。
Perhaps after Tammy came clean to Brad about her relationship with Brian, she had pushed Brian to do the same with his spouse. Maybe she wanted Brian to get a divorce, but he wasn't prepared to do so. Tammy might have threatened to approach Brian's wife herself, which could have pushed him over the edge. The blood pointed towards Brad, who undisputedly had access to Tammy's vehicle. However, if Brad was telling the truth about trailing Tammy and her boyfriend in the early morning hours of Wednesday, February 8, it was possible that Brian had killed Tammy and then planted blood on her vehicle in an attempt to frame Brad. Both men had a motive, but only one of them could be telling the truth. Inquiries were made with the Highway Patrol Unit to check Brad's claim that he'd broken down while trailing Tammy.
比赛结束后，他和家人一起回家，再也没有离开过家，直到第二天早上上班。布拉德向公路巡查队进行了查询，以核实他尾随塔米时汽车抛锚的说法。
Dashcam footage confirmed that at 1.40am, a state trooper had found the derango pulled over on the side of the road with Brad rear behind the wheel. The trooper asked Brad for ID, but he said he didn't have any as he was just ducking out to grab something from the store. He willingly provided his full name, and the trooper didn't notice anything suspicious about his behaviour. Nor did he see anything strange in or on the car. Once Brad got the car started again, he drove off in the direction of his home. The detectives now had confirmation of the story he had consistently told them from the beginning. With so many unanswered questions, the case couldn't progress any further until Tammy was found. When morning broke on Thursday, February 9, a search party made up of police officers, firefighters and local volunteers
行车记录仪画面证实，凌晨1点40分，一名州警发现那辆杜兰戈车停在路边，布拉德坐在驾驶座后面。警察向布拉德索要身份证，但他说自己没有带，因为他只是出来从商店买点东西。他爽快地报出了自己的全名，警察没有发现他有任何可疑的行为。也没有在车内或车上发现任何奇怪的地方。布拉德重新发动汽车后，朝他家的方向开去。侦探们现在证实了他从一开始就一直讲述的故事。由于有这么多未解之谜，在找到塔米之前，案件无法取得进一步进展。2月9日星期四破晓时分，由警察、消防员和当地志愿者组成的搜寻队
gathered to comb the vast countryside surrounding Peer. Time was of the essence. The hills around the city saw very little foot traffic, except for the hunters who flocked to the area between October and January. Hunting season had just concluded. This meant that if Tammy was lying undiscovered in the area, it was highly unlikely that anyone would come across her body until the next hunting season began in eight months time. By that point, wild animals would have likely found her first. On foot and with the help of cadaver dogs, the search party covered mile upon mile of the rolling hills and prairies. Law enforcement managed to secure a helicopter from the National Guard to cover the area overhead, but even with the advantage of a bird's eye view, there was no sign of Tammy anywhere.
聚集在一起，对皮尔周边广袤的乡村进行了地毯式搜寻。时间就是生命。这座城市周围的山丘极少有人涉足，除了10月到1月蜂拥至该地区的猎人们。狩猎季刚刚结束。这意味着如果塔米不为人知地躺在这个地区，在8个月后下一个狩猎季开始之前，极不可能有人会偶然发现她的尸体。到那个时候，野生动物可能已经先找到她了。搜寻队靠步行并在搜尸犬的协助下，搜寻了起伏的山丘和草原一英里又一英里。执法部门设法从国民警卫队调来了一架直升机从空中搜寻该地区，但即使有鸟瞰视角的优势，到处也看不到塔米的踪迹。
As the sun began to descend for the day, the helicopter pilot decided to do one last sweep of an isolated prairie approximately 10 miles north of Peer. As they passed over a spillway running off the Awahi dam, they noticed something in the rugged terrain below. It was the naked body of Tammy Rhea. Tammy had been stabbed upwards of 35 times and her throat had been slashed. It appeared that some of the injuries had been made after she was already dead, sometime after the initial attack. Her hands were covered in knife wounds, indicating she had attempted to fight off her killer. One cut was so deep that the bone had been exposed, as though Tammy had taken hold of the knife during the attack. It was the most extreme case of overkill that attending detectives had ever witnessed.
当太阳开始西沉时，直升机飞行员决定对皮尔以北大约10英里处的一个偏远草原进行最后一次巡视。当他们飞越奥瓦希大坝延伸出的泄洪道时，他们注意到下方崎岖的地形中有东西。那是塔米·里亚赤裸的尸体。塔米被刺了35刀以上，喉咙也被割断。看起来有些伤是在她已经死后才造成的，在最初的袭击发生一段时间之后。她的双手布满刀伤，表明她曾试图击退凶手。其中一处伤口非常深，连骨头都露出来了，就像塔米在袭击过程中抓住过刀子一样。这是在场侦探们见过的最极端残忍的过度杀戮案件。
Yet, there was no blood on the scene, meaning that the attack itself had occurred elsewhere. Officers searched the area for clues and found a t-shirt shredded with knife cuts, as well as a pair of blood-stained gloves. Nothing was found that identified the killer. Tammy's father, Don, was nearing Peer on his drive from Wyoming when his cell phone rang and a police officer broke the dreaded news that Tammy's body had been found. To save him the pain of seeing her injuries, Don was told he wouldn't need to formally identify his daughter. Haley had been hoping with all her might that her mother would be found alive. When she received the terrible news, she refused to believe that Brad could be responsible. There was no way that the father she knew could be capable of such a heinous crime.
然而，现场没有血迹，这意味着袭击本身发生在其他地方。警察在现场搜寻线索，找到了一件被刀割破的T恤以及一双沾满血迹的手套。没有发现任何可以确认凶手身份的物品。塔米的父亲唐（Don）从怀俄明州驾车正接近皮尔时，手机响了，一名警官打破了令人恐惧的消息：塔米的尸体被找到了。为了免除他看到女儿伤势的痛苦，唐被告知他不需要正式辨认女儿的尸体。海莉曾竭尽全力希望母亲能活着被找到。当她听到这个可怕的消息时，她拒绝相信布拉德会是罪魁祸首。她认识的父亲绝不可能做出如此凶残的罪行。
Tammy's body was autopsyed, but it didn't reveal any forensic evidence tying either Brad or Brian to her murder. Police returned to the Rhea property and conducted another search, this time testing surfaces around the house with luminal. Once again, they found nothing. Tammy and Brad had been sleeping in separate bedrooms and both their beds were microscopically examined, but there was no trace of blood anywhere. Investigators began to wonder if they had arrested an innocent man. The evidence simply wasn't adding up against Brad Rhea. Instead, they turned their attention to Brian Clark. They had no choice but to question Brian's wife, Kerry, not her real name, in turn forcing Brian to break the news to her about his affair with Tammy.
塔米的尸体被进行了尸检，但没有发现任何将布拉德或布莱恩与她的谋杀案联系起来的法医证据。警察返回里亚的住所进行了另一次搜查，这次用鲁米诺（luminol）试剂测试了房子周围的表面。他们再次一无所获。塔米和布拉德一直睡在不同的卧室里，他们的床都经过了显微镜级别的检查，但到处都没有血迹的痕迹。调查人员开始怀疑他们是否逮捕了一个无辜的人。证据根本无法指证布拉德·里亚。相反，他们将注意力转向了布莱恩·克拉克。他们别无选择，只能盘问布莱恩的妻子克里（Kerry，化名），这反过来迫使布莱恩向她坦白了他与塔米的外遇。
Kerry was obviously crushed, but when the detectives asked her about Brian's whereabouts on the night of Tuesday, February 7, she confirmed that he had been with her and their daughter at a local basketball game. Afterwards, they spent the rest of the night at home. But there was one problem. Although Kerry and Brian shared at the same bedroom, Kerry suffered from ongoing back pain and sometimes slept in a recliner chair downstairs. The night Tammy was killed, she had slept in the recliner. This meant it was possible that Brian had sneaked out in the middle of the night without his wife's knowledge. Brad remained in custody while the investigation continued. Haley hoped the police would find the evidence to clear her father so that she wouldn't have to live without both of her parents.
克里显然心碎了，但当侦探询问她关于2月7日星期二晚上布莱恩的下落时，她证实他和她以及他们的女儿在一起看当地的一场篮球比赛。之后，他们在家度过了剩下的夜晚。但有一个问题。尽管克里和布拉德共用同一间卧室，但克里长期背痛，有时睡在楼下的躺椅上。塔米被杀的那天晚上，她就睡在躺椅上。这意味着布莱恩有可能在妻子不知情的情况下在半夜溜出去。在调查继续期间，布拉德仍然被拘留。海莉希望警方能找到证据来洗清她父亲的嫌疑，这样她就不必在失去双亲的情况下生活了。
But investigators still didn't have any evidence to charge Brian and there were no other suspects. However, with no crime scene and no hard proof who the killer was, the case couldn't proceed to trial until the prosecution could build a solid case against Brad. Then on March 9, one month after Tammy's murder, an envelope arrived at the office of the Attorney General that contained some startling revelations. Inside the envelope was a letter written by one of Brian Clark's cousins. He had information that he needed to get off his chest. According to the letter, Brian had confided that on the afternoon of Tuesday, February 7, he and Tammy had met at the Fawn Motel where they had sex. They wanted to meet up again later so that night, Brian drove to Tammy's house for a second rendezvous. The couple took some blankets and drove Tammy's derango out to a remote area. They laid the blankets down and Tammy removed all of her clothes except for her t-shirt.
但调查人员仍然没有任何证据来起诉布莱恩，也没有其他嫌疑人。然而，在没有犯罪现场、也没有确凿证据证明谁是凶手的情况下，在控方能够针对布拉德建立起强有力的案件之前，案件无法进入审判程序。接着在3月9日，即塔米被害一个月后，总检察长办公室收到了一封信，里面包含了一些令人震惊的内幕。信封里面是一封由布莱恩·克拉克的一个表弟写的信。他有一些需要一吐为快的内幕信息。根据信件内容，布莱恩曾吐露，在2月7日星期二下午，他和塔米在法恩汽车旅馆见面并发生了性关系。他们想晚些时候再次见面，所以那天晚上，布莱恩开车去塔米家进行第二次幽会。这对男女拿了一些毯子，开着塔米的杜兰戈车去了一个偏远地区。他们铺好毯子，塔米脱掉了身上除了T恤以外所有的衣服。
She then asked Brian to use a condom but Brian didn't want to. Tammy insisted which triggered a surge of rage in Brian. They began fighting and Brian forced himself on Tammy, raping her. She tried to fight him off, losing her wedding ring in the process. During the attack, the condom came off inside of Tammy's body. In a violent frenzy, Brian took out a knife and began stabbing Tammy. She tried to get up and run away but Brian chased after her and fatally stabbed her in the back. He then wrapped her body in the blankets they had brought and loaded her into the derango.
然后她要求布莱恩使用安全套，但布莱恩不愿意。塔米坚持要求，这引发了布莱恩心头的一股怒火。他们开始争吵，布莱恩强暴了塔米。她试图反抗，在这个过程中弄丢了她的结婚戒指。袭击过程中，安全套脱落在了塔米体内。在暴力的狂乱中，布莱恩掏出一把刀开始捅刺塔米。她试图爬起来逃跑，但布莱恩追了上去，并在她背上致命地捅了一刀。然后他用他们带去的毯子包裹了她的尸体，并把她装上了杜兰戈车。
After dumping Tammy's body, he drove the vehicle back to her house and parked it in the garage. Brian had subsequently confided the details of this attack to his cousin who helped him get rid of evidence. The information provided throughout the letter matched several known aspects of the crime that hadn't been released to the public. There was no way the letter's author could have known these details unless they had intimate knowledge from the killer themselves. But there was one detail that didn't quite make sense. Tammy's body had been autopsied and there was no condom found inside her as Brian's cousin claimed. Determined to find out the truth, investigators called for a second autopsy. Upon re-examination, the pathologist discovered that there was indeed a used condom lodged inside Tammy's body.
在抛弃了塔米的尸体后，他把车开回她家并停在车库里。布莱恩随后向他的表弟吐露了这次袭击的细节，表弟帮他清理了证据。这封信中提供的信息与犯罪的几个已知但未向公众披露的细节相吻合。这封信的作者绝不可能知道这些细节，除非他们从凶手本人那里得知了内幕。但有一个细节有点说不通。塔米的尸体经过了尸检，里面并没有像布莱恩表弟所声称的那样发现安全套。为了弄清真相，调查人员要求进行第二次尸检。经重新检查，病理学家发现塔米体内确实卡着一个用过的安全套。
A crucial piece of evidence that had somehow been missed during the first post-mortem examination. It appeared that Brian's cousin was telling the truth. The condom promised to be the major breakthrough the investigators had been waiting for. It was forensically tested in the hopes it would identify Tammy's killer once and for all. Unfortunately, due to the amount of time it had spent inside Tammy's body, all traces of DNA had degraded and couldn't be identified. What had looked like a promising piece of evidence was now raising even more questions. Whoever wrote the letter clearly had inside a knowledge of Tammy's murder, but there still wasn't any physical evidence to back their claim that Brian Clark was the killer.
这枚至关重要的证据在第一次尸检时不知为何被漏掉了。看起来布莱恩的表弟说的是实话。这个安全套有望成为调查人员一直等待的重大突破。经过法医检测，希望能借此一劳永逸地查明塔米的凶手。不幸的是，由于它在塔米体内呆的时间太久，所有的DNA痕迹都已经降解，无法被识别。曾经看起来大有希望的证据现在引发了更多的疑窦。无论谁写了这封信，显然都对塔米的谋杀案心知肚明，但仍然没有任何实质证据来支持他们关于布莱恩·克拉克是凶手的指控。
The biggest problem was that investigators still had no idea where the murder had been committed. Police returned to the Rhea home to conduct yet another search, hoping to find even the smallest of clues. As one officer rummaged through Brad's dresser drawers, they came across something of interest. It was a small digital audio recorder. As they pressed play, a static noise filled the air. The officer waited, but nothing else followed. Finally, after about 15 minutes of static, Tammy's voice filled the room. It sounded as though the recording had captured her side of a phone conversation.
最大的问题是调查人员仍然不知道谋杀案是在哪里发生的。警察返回里亚的住宅进行了又一次搜查，希望能找到哪怕最小的线索。正当一名警官在翻找布拉德的梳妆台抽屉时，他们偶然发现了一个有趣的东西。那是一个小型数字录音机。当他们按下播放键时，沙沙的噪音充满了整个房间。警官等待着，但没有后续声音。最后，在大约15分钟的静电噪音之后，塔米的声音充满了整个房间。听起来录音记录了她在一场电话对话中的那一头。
The officer listened as Tammy asked to speak to Brian Clark. When Brian presumably picked up the other line, Tammy told him, It's just me, I just needed to hear your voice. They chatted for a few minutes before Tammy said, I love you very, very much. From the beginning of the investigation, Brad had maintained that he didn't know who Tammy was dating, but the recording clearly featured Brian's first and last names. If the audio recorder belonged to Brad, then this was irrefutable proof that he'd been lying.
警察听着塔米要求与布莱恩·克拉克通话。当布莱恩大概接起另一端电话时，塔米对他说：“是我，我只是想听听你的声音。”他们闲聊了几分钟，然后塔米说：“我非常非常爱你。”从调查一开始，布拉德就坚称自己不知道塔米在和谁约会，但录音中清晰地出现了布莱恩的名字和姓氏。如果录音机属于布拉德，那么这就是他一直在撒谎的无可辩驳的证据。
However, the officers were aware that just because the device was found in Brad's drawer, it didn't necessarily mean it belonged to him or that he knew what was on it. Investigators got to work trying to figure out when the phone calling question had been recorded. They discovered that the recording was made just four days prior to Tammy's murder. The police were also able to recover some deleted digital files. When an investigator hit play on one of the files, a voice spoke over static airspace, testing to see whether the recorder worked by slowly saying, One, two, three, four.
然而，警官们深知，设备在布拉德的抽屉里被发现，并不一定意味着它属于他，也不代表他知道里面录了什么。调查人员开始着手查明这个受质疑的电话录音是什么时候被录下的。他们发现，这段录音是在塔米遇害仅仅四天前制作的。警察还设法恢复了一些被删除的数字文件。当调查人员点击播放其中一个文件时，沙沙的杂音中传出了一个声音，通过缓缓说出“一、二、三、四”来测试录音机是否正常工作。
It was Brad Rhea. It was clear that Brad had been the one to record Tammy's phone conversation with Brian. With police now able to prove that he was lying about knowing who Tammy's boyfriend was, they had to consider what else he could be lying about. The transcripts of his initial police interrogation were reviewed, and one investigator noted something that stuck out as odd. When the heat was placed on him for Tammy's murder, Brad said, All this evidence points at me, but I'm hoping that the body is found,
那是布拉德·雷亚的声音。显然，录下塔米与布赖恩电话交谈的人正是布拉德。既然警方现在能够证明他在“不知道塔米的男朋友是谁”这件事上撒谎，他们就不得不考虑他还可能在哪些事情上撒谎。他们重新审视了他最初接受警方审讯的文字记录，一位调查人员注意到一个显得有些奇怪的细节。当因塔米的谋杀案而受到严厉逼问时，布拉德说：“所有这些证据都指向我，但我希望能够找到尸体，
because there'll be something to set me free. Maybe DNA, something like that. Investigators believed this suggested Brad knew the used condom would be found inside Tammy's body, most likely because he had planted it there in an attempt to frame Brian Clark. But if this was the case, how would he have obtained a condom with Brian's DNA on it? Investigators questioned Brian and learned that he would sometimes dispose of used condoms by throwing them out of his car window. Investigators began to suspect that Brad had tailed Tammy and Brian on more than one occasion. He had already admitted to having done so on the night of his wife's murder.
因为那样就会有东西能让我重获自由。也许是DNA之类的东西。”调查人员认为，这表明布拉德知道那个用过的避孕套会在塔米的体内被发现，最可能是因为那是他亲手藏进去的，企图嫁祸给布赖恩·克拉克。但如果真是这样，他是怎么弄到一个带有布赖恩DNA的避孕套的呢？调查人员盘问了布赖恩，得知他有时会通过把车窗摇下往外扔的方式来处理用过的避孕套。调查人员开始怀疑，布拉德不止一次地尾随过塔米和布赖恩。他其实已经在妻子遇害当晚承认过这一点。
Police believed he had most likely followed them before and saw Brian throw away the condom, prompting him to hatch a plan to frame Brian by planting his DNA on Tammy's body. He likely didn't know that the DNA could disintegrate over time when exposed to bodily acids. Brad had probably been confident that the condom would exonerate him. For some time, investigators had been recording Brad's phone conversations in jail in the hopes they might hear something that would finally solve the case. Brad had a twin brother named Brett Rayer, whom he spoke to regularly. During one conversation between the brothers, Brad had told Brett to bring a notepad next time he came to visit. Detectives thought this seemed suspicious, so they set up a covert video camera to capture the meeting.
警方认为，他很可能以前就跟踪过他们，并看到布赖恩扔掉了避孕套，这促使他萌生了一个计划：把布赖恩的DNA植入塔米体内，以此栽赃布赖恩。他大概并不知道，DNA在接触到体液酸性物质时会随着时间推移而分解。布拉德当时可能深信这个避孕套能帮他脱罪。一段时间以来，调查人员一直在监听布拉德在监狱里的电话，希望能听到最终破案的关键线索。布拉德有一个双胞胎兄弟叫布雷特·雷亚，他经常跟这个兄弟通话。在兄弟俩的一次通话中，布拉德告诉布雷特下次来探视时带个记事本。侦探们觉得这很可疑，于是安装了一个隐蔽摄像机来记录这次会面。
Brett sat down opposite Brad in a meeting room separated by plexiglass. Brad told his brother that he wanted him to send some letters on his behalf. Then he pressed a piece of paper up against the glass. Brett examined the paper and took out a yellow notebook, quickly scribbling down some notes. Brad said, there's a reason behind it. Do you see where I'm going with this stuff? After Brett left the jail, police trailed his car. They watched as he posted some letters. Later that day, they eventually pulled Brett over three hours west of Peer in the South Dakota town of Spearfish.
布雷特坐在由有机玻璃隔开的会面室里，与布拉德相对而坐。布拉德告诉兄弟，他想让他代为寄几封信。接着，他把一张纸贴在玻璃上。布雷特仔细查看了那张纸，拿出一个黄色笔记本，迅速记下了一些笔记。布拉德说：“这背后是有原因的。你明白我这些话是什么意思吗？”布雷特离开监狱后，警方开始尾随他的车。他们看着他寄出了几封信。当天晚些时候，他们最终在南达科他州斯皮尔菲什镇、皮尔以西三小时车程的地方截停了布雷特。
They searched his car and found the yellow notebook. In it were notes containing the same details that appeared in the letter that eventually arrived at the office of the Attorney General claiming to be from a cousin of Brian Clark. Brett Rhea was arrested and charged with being an accessory to a felony. Brad denied asking his brother to write a letter framing Brian. He claimed the visit in jail was simply because he owned some valuable baseball cards that he wanted Brett to secure for him. Given that the letter contained details only the killer could know, investigators now knew for certain that Brad was the real perpetrator. However, from a legal standpoint, there still wasn't any physical evidence tying him to Tammy's murder. If the case went to court, state prosecutors couldn't be sure there was enough for a jury to find him guilty.
他们搜查了他的车，并找到了那个黄色笔记本。里面记录的内容，与后来寄到总检察长办公室、自称是布赖恩·克拉克表弟的那封信中的细节完全一致。布雷特·雷亚因涉嫌协助重罪犯而被捕并起诉。布拉德否认曾要求兄弟写信陷害布赖恩。他声称这次监狱会面纯粹是因为他有一些贵重的棒球卡，想让布雷特帮他妥善保管。鉴于信中包含了只有凶手才知道的细节，调查人员现在确信布拉德才是真正的凶手。然而从法律角度来看，仍然没有任何直接的物资金属证据将他与塔米的谋杀案联系起来。如果案件诉诸法庭，州检察官无法确信现有的证据足以让陪审团判定他有罪。
Then investigators came across another letter. This one was written by Brad to his twin brother, Brett. In it, Brad described some good fishing spots near Peer. He drew a map directing Brett to several locations around the O'wahy Dam. With Brad facing charges for murder, investigators thought it unlikely that he was focused on something as trivial as fishing. They were convinced these locations held some other kind of significance. With the help of sniffer dogs, a search team went to check the locations Brad had pinpointed on his map. At an area near the O'wahy Dam power station, they foraged through the scrub and came upon a cluster of juniper bushes.
随后，调查人员发现了另一封信。这封信是布拉德写给他的双胞胎兄弟布雷特的。信中，布拉德描述了皮尔附近的一些好钓鱼点。他画了一张地图，指引布雷特前往奥瓦希水坝周围的几个地点。鉴于布拉德正面临谋杀指控，调查人员认为他不可能把心思放在钓鱼这么琐碎的事情上。他们确信这些地点有着某种其他的特殊意义。在搜救犬的协助下，搜查队前往检查布拉德在地图上标注的位置。在奥瓦希水坝发电厂附近的一个区域，他们在灌木丛中搜寻，发现了一簇杜松灌木。
Hidden among them were three black garbage bags. Inside were several items of bedding, including sheets, blankets, quilts and pillowcases. All were soaked with blood. One of the bags also contained a pair of bloody rubber gloves, women's underwear and an open box of condoms. One was missing. The bedding and blood were confirmed to be Tammies. Amongst the linens was another particularly interesting item, a large bloodstained tarpaulin. Given there was no blood evidence found inside the rear home, the tarp allowed investigators to piece together a probable scenario.
藏在其中的是三个黑色垃圾袋。里面装了几件寝具，包括床单、毯子、被子和枕套。所有的东西都被血浸透了。其中一个袋子里还包含一双带血的橡胶手套、女性内衣和一盒打开的避孕套。少了一个。经证实，这些寝具和血迹都属于塔米。在亚麻织物中还有另一件特别有趣的物品，一个沾满血迹的大篷布。鉴于后屋内部没有发现血迹证据，这块防水布让调查人员得以拼凑出一个最有可能的犯罪场景。
They deduced that Brad had likely fitted the tarp over Tammies mattress without her knowledge, then lined it with several sheets so she wouldn't be able to feel it was there. After she went to bed on the night of February 7, Brad walked in and launched a brutal attack, stabbing her five times in the back and slitting her throat while she slept. The amount of blankets on the bed would have instantly soaked up the blood and prevented any spatter, explaining why there was no blood found at the crime scene. Afterwards, Brad had wrapped Tammies body in the blankets and tarp, then carried her out to the garage, which was only five feet away from her bedroom. He loaded her into the Durango and planted the used condom inside her. Either while they were in the vehicle or when they arrived at the Awahi Dam spillway, Brad decided to launch another attack, inflicting multiple stab wounds to Tammies chest. Finally, he disposed of her body and the garbage bags full of evidence. As for Brad's story about breaking down on the side of the road and having a conversation with a highway patrol officer, investigators theorized that this was likely a close call.
他们推断，布拉德很可能在塔米不知情的情况下将防水布铺在她的床垫上，然后在上面铺了几层床单，这样她就感觉不到它的存在。2月7日夜里她上床睡觉后，布拉德走了进来，发动了一场残忍的袭击，在她熟睡时从背后捅了她五刀并割断了她的喉咙。床上的大量毯子会瞬间吸干血迹并防止任何血溅，这就解释了为什么案发现场没有发现血迹。事后，布拉德将塔米的尸体包裹在毯子和防水布里，然后把她搬到距离她卧室仅五英尺的车库。他把她搬上杜兰戈汽车，并将用过的避孕套塞进她体内。无论是在车里还是到达奥瓦希水坝泄洪道时，布拉德决定再次发动袭击，对塔米的胸部造成多处刺伤。最后，他处理掉了她的尸体和装满证据的垃圾袋。至于布拉德关于车子在路边抛锚并与一名公路巡警交谈的说法，调查人员推测这很可能是一次千钧一发的险情。
Brad had been driving in the direction of Brian Clark's house, and it was possible that he had been heading there with the intention of planting evidence. He'd likely assumed the condom would be found and DNA testing would link it back to Brian, thereby framing him for the murder. But, once Brad realized this key piece of evidence was missed during Tammies autopsy, he hatched a scheme to write false confession letters and enlisted his twin brother's help to send them from outside of jail. At the time of Brad's arrest, traces of vegetation were found on his shoes. These were tested and confirmed to match the Juniper bushes where the blood-soaked evidence was dumped. Furthermore, the garbage bags used to dispose of the evidence were the exact same kind as others found inside the Rhea home. This is undisputedly placed here at the crime scene, and the existence of the tarp indicated premeditation. With all of these elements combined, the prosecution finally felt they had a strong enough case to take Brad to trial.
布拉德当时正朝布赖恩·克拉克的房子方向开车，有可能他当时正打算去那里栽赃证据。他很可能以为避孕套会被发现，而DNA检测会将其与布赖恩联系起来，从而将谋杀罪嫁祸给他。但是，一旦布拉德意识到这一关键证据在塔米的尸检中被漏掉了，他便策划了虚假供词信件，并拉拢他的双胞胎兄弟帮忙从监狱外面寄出。在布拉德被捕时，他的鞋上发现了植物残留物。经测试，这些残留物与倾倒血迹证据的杜松灌木完全吻合。此外，用于处理证据的垃圾袋与在雷亚家中发现的其他垃圾袋完全是同一类型。这无可争辩地将他与案发现场联系在一起，而防水布的存在则表明这是预谋作案。结合所有这些要素，检方终于觉得他们有足够的证据将布拉德送上法庭审判。
The trial commenced in January of 2007, with Brad Rhea pleading not guilty to first-degree murder. Considering the death penalty wasn't being sought, South Dakota law dictated that if Brad was convicted, he'd automatically receive a mandatory life sentence. The prosecution anticipated a short trial for what they believed to be an open and shut case, but Brad made a rare decision for a defendant. He agreed to take the stand in his own defense. No one quite knew what to expect when it came time for him to testify. What he said shocked the courtroom, especially members of Tammy's family. Unable to conceal the lies any longer, Brad felt he finally had to come clean. It wasn't him who killed Tammy, but he's now 13-year-old daughter Haley.
审判于2007年1月开始，布拉德·雷亚对一级谋杀指控做出了无罪抗辩。考虑到检方并未寻求死刑，南达科他州法律规定，如果布拉德被定罪，他将自动面临强制性的终身监禁。检方原本预计这场看似板上钉钉的案件审理过程会很短，但布拉德做出了被告中罕见的决定。他同意出庭为自己作证。当轮到他作证时，没有人知道会发生什么。他在法庭上的言论震惊了所有人，尤其是塔米的家人。由于无法再掩盖谎言，布拉德觉得自己终于必须说出真相了。杀害塔米的不是他，而是他当时13岁的女儿海莉。
He testified that the trouble began when he and Tammy told Haley they were getting a divorce. Haley was devastated. She liked her house and her family and didn't want anything to change. She was furious that her parents didn't want to work things out and had been depressed about the impending divorce for days. On the night of Tuesday, February 7, Brad came home late from work to find both Tammy and Haley already asleep. He went to bed himself, only to be awoken around midnight by the family's cat. He heard some noise from Tammy's room and went to see what it was. To his shock, he saw Haley standing over Tammy's body. She was covered in blood and holding a knife.
他作证说，麻烦始于他和塔米告诉海莉他们要离婚的时候。海莉心碎了。她喜欢她的房子和家庭，不希望任何事情改变。她对父母不愿修复关系感到愤怒，并且对即将到来的离婚情绪低落了好几天。2月7日星期二晚上，布拉德工作很晚回家，发现塔米和海莉都睡着了。他自己也上床睡觉了，但在午夜左右被家里的猫吵醒。他听到塔米房间里有动静，便过去查看是怎么回事。令他震惊的是，他看到海莉站在塔米的尸体上方。她浑身是血，手里拿着一把刀。
Her nose was also bleeding as a result of being hit by Tammy as she fought back. Brad cried out, asking Haley what she'd done, but Haley didn't respond. She was catatonic. Brad jumped on Tammy and tried to give her mouth-to-mouth resuscitation, but it was no use. She was already dead. Haley showed no emotion or reaction and seemed barely conscious. It was then that Brad realized she was sleepwalking. In a panic, he carried Haley back to bed and wiped all the blood off of her.
由于遭到拼命反抗的塔米殴打，她的鼻子也在流血。布拉德大声质问海莉做了什么，但海莉没有回应。她处于紧张性精神症（木僵）状态。布拉德扑向塔米，试图给她做人工呼吸，但无济于事。她已经死了。海莉没有表现出任何情绪或反应，几乎毫无意识。就在那时，布拉德意识到她在梦游。在惊慌失措中，他把海莉抱回床上，擦掉了她身上的血迹。
Then he tried to clean up the crime scene. He bundled up the blood-soaked bed linens, threw their bloodied clothing in the washing machine, and carried Tammy's body into her car. Wanting to protect his daughter, he made the snap decision to plant the condom in an attempt to blame the man Tammy was dating. When Haley woke the next day, she acted completely normal, and it was clear to Brad that she had no recollection of what had happened. His initial plan had been to take Haley and flee to Mexico, but he was arrested before he could act on it. Brad said Haley had always exhibited some troubling behaviors, claiming that when she was a child, she used to stab her stuffed animals. Brad knew his daughter needed psychological treatment, but didn't think she'd get it if she was sent to prison, so he decided to lie to authorities to protect her. He acknowledged that he'd broken the law and should be charged accordingly.
然后他试图清理案发现场。他把沾满血迹的床单卷起来，把他们带血的衣服扔进洗衣机，并把塔米的尸体搬进她的车里。出于保护女儿的愿望，他临时做出决定，将避孕套放进体内，企图将罪名推给塔米正在约会的那个男人。海莉第二天醒来时，表现得完全正常，布拉德清楚她对发生的事情毫无记忆。他最初的计划是带着海莉逃往墨西哥，但他在付诸行动之前就被捕了。布拉德说海莉一直表现出一些令人不安的行为，并声称她小时候曾刺伤过她的毛绒玩具。布拉德知道女儿需要心理治疗，但认为如果她被送进监狱就无法接受治疗，于是他决定向当局撒谎来保护她。他承认自己触犯了法律，应该受到相应的指控。
But because his lies were based on the desire to protect his daughter, he urged the jury not to find him guilty of murder. Brad's lawyer argued that because Haley was unconscious when she stabbed Tammy, she couldn't be held legally responsible, telling the jury, there's a lot that could have been going on between Haley and Tammy without us knowing about it. He referenced Haley's strong athletic abilities, with particular focus on her volleyball skills, indicating that her overarm serving style was similar to the downward stabbing motion used in Tammy's murder. The defense lawyer said, if Brad Rhea is telling us the truth, shame on us all. Brad watched intently as Haley was put on the stand. She vehemently denied his accusations. Haley spoke of her deep love for her mother and said she would never have done anything to hurt her. This contrasted with her relationship to her father. Haley had never been very close to Brad and was now afraid of him. On the night of Tammy's murder, Haley went to sleep with her bedroom door open.
但由于他的谎言是基于保护女儿的愿望，他敦促陪审团不要判处他谋杀罪。布拉德的律师辩称，由于海莉刺伤塔米时处于无意识状态，因此她不应承担法律责任，他告诉陪审团：“海莉和塔米之间可能发生了很多我们不知道的事情。”他提到了海莉强劲的运动能力，特别是专注于她的排球技能，暗示她的上臂发球风格类似于塔米谋杀案中使用的向下刺击动作。辩护律师说：“如果布拉德·雷亚对我们说的是实话，那我们所有人都该感到羞耻。”海莉出庭时，布拉德目不转睛地看着她。她强烈否认了他的指控。海莉谈到了她对母亲的深切爱意，并表示她绝不会做任何伤害母亲的事。这与她和父亲的关系形成了鲜明对比。海莉从未与布拉德很亲近，现在甚至有些害怕他。在塔米遇害的那天晚上，海莉睡觉时卧室的门是开着的。
At around midnight, she woke up to find it was closed. Her father opened the door and was holding an armful of clothing. Haley asked what he was doing, to which Brad replied, nothing. He put the clothes down and laid down in Haley's bed, telling her he loved her. Haley fell back asleep and when she woke the next morning, her mother was gone and her father was doing laundry. When she had asked him where her mother was, Brad had initially claimed she was in her room. But Haley had checked the entire house and there was no trace of Tammy. As for the lawyer's inference that she was capable of stabbing her mother based on her volleyball serve, Haley said she didn't use an overarm serve at all, but an underarm one. The prosecution was outraged by Brad's claim that Haley was the killer.
大约在午夜时分，她醒来发现门被关上了。她的父亲打开门，手里抱着一大堆衣服。海莉问他在做什么，布拉德回答说：“没什么。”他放下衣服，躺在海莉的床上，告诉她他爱她。海莉又睡着了，第二天早上醒来时，她的母亲不见了，父亲正在洗衣服。当她问他母亲在哪里时，布拉德最初声称她在自己的房间里。但海莉检查了整个房子，根本没有塔米的踪迹。至于律师根据她的排球发球推断她有能力刺死母亲的说法，海莉说她根本不使用上臂发球，而是用下臂发球。检方对布拉德声称海莉是凶手的说法感到愤怒。
The stab wounds on Tammy's body were incredibly deep, some two inches longer than the blade of the weapon itself. The sheer force of the knife wounds alone couldn't have been afflicted by someone of Haley's size, nor did she have any history of sleepwalking. During cross-examination, Brad said that he and Tammy had a happy marriage, but his long work hours had ultimately driven her away. Arguing against Haley's claim that she wasn't close with him, Brad claimed they were so close that he was willing to go to prison for her. Brad's testimony only served to hurt his defense, as he gave inconsistent answers to facts that had already been established. He claimed he didn't know Tammy was having an affair until after he was arrested, even though he'd already admitted this fact to detectives when Tammy was first reported missing. He also claimed that the blood Haley was covered in was predominantly from her bloody nose, not Tammy's injuries. Given how many wounds were inflicted, this seemed highly unlikely.
塔米身上的刀伤极其深，有些比凶器本身的刀刃还要长两英寸。仅凭刀伤的纯粹力量，是不可能由海莉这样身材的人造成的，而且她也没有任何梦游史。在盘问过程中，布拉德声称他和塔米婚姻美满，但自己长时间的工作最终逼走了她。针对海莉“与他并不亲密”的说法，布拉德辩称他们关系非常亲密，以至于他愿意为她入狱。布拉德的证词只会削弱他的辩护，因为他对已经确立的事实给出了矛盾的回答。他声称直到被捕后才知道塔米有婚外情，尽管在塔米最初被报失踪时，他已经向侦探承认了这一事实。他还声称海莉身上沾满的血主要是她自己流鼻血的血，而不是塔米受伤的血。考虑到造成的伤口数量，这显得极不可信。
Similarly, he said that when giving Tammy mouth-to-mouth resuscitation, he didn't notice any stab wounds, just blood. Given the amount of injuries to Tammy's chest, the prosecution argued it would have been impossible not to notice the wounds if Brad really did attempt to revive her. Brad's attempt to place the blame on his daughter was fruitless. His brother, Brett, had already admitted to writing the letters aimed at framing Brian Clark. After his arrest, Brett had cooperated fully with investigators, agreeing to testify against his twin in exchange for being released from jail after serving 172 days. Brett said he was genuinely sorry for the part he played and regretted trying to help Brad. Brett told the court his brother deserved to be sent to prison. He was released immediately after testifying.
同样，他说在给塔米做人工呼吸时，他没有注意到任何刀伤，只有血。鉴于塔米胸部的伤势数量，检方辩称，如果布拉德真的试图对她进行复活急救，绝不可能注意不到这些伤口。布拉德试图将罪责推卸给女儿的企图毫无结果。他的兄弟布雷特已经承认写了旨在陷害布赖恩·克拉克的信件。被捕后，布雷特全力配合调查人员，同意指证他的双胞胎兄弟，以此换取在服刑172天后被释放出狱。布雷特表示，他对自己所扮演的角色感到真诚的抱歉，并后悔曾试图帮助布拉德。布雷特告诉法庭，他的兄弟罪有应得，应该被送进监狱。他在作证后立即被释放。
The judge believed he had already suffered enough. The twins' mother had recently passed away from an aneurysm after visiting her sons in jail. It was also revealed just how Brad had figured out who Tammy was dating. He'd bugged her car with the audio recording device and then placed a bunch of flowers in the vehicle along with a letter that read, I'm sorry, let's make up. Just as Brad had hoped, Tammy thought the flowers were from her boyfriend and called Brian to thank him, thus revealing his identity to Brad. It took the jury just three hours to find Brad Rhea guilty of first-degree murder.
法官认为他已经受够了折磨。这对双胞胎的母亲在探望完在监狱里的儿子们后不久，便因动脉瘤不幸离世。调查人员还揭露了布拉德是如何弄清楚塔米在和谁约会的。他在她的车里安装了录音设备，然后在车里放了一束花以及一封信，上面写着：“对不起，我们和好吧。”正如布拉德所希望的那样，塔米以为这些花是男友送的，便打电话给布赖恩向他致谢，从而将他的身份暴露给了布拉德。陪审团仅用了三个小时就裁定布拉德·雷亚一级谋杀罪名成立。
His attempt to place the blame on Hailey had made him look more guilty and only served to anger members of the jury. The prosecutor stated, Brad was one of the best witnesses I had. His testimony hurt him a bunch. Following the verdict, Tammy's family released a statement that read, Justice was finally served and all the lies can stop. Tammy was such a wonderful person with such a zest for life. Unfortunately, she was not given an opportunity to make a better life for herself and Hailey.
他试图将责任推给海莉的举动让他看起来更加罪责难逃，并只招致了陪审团成员的愤怒。检察官表示：“布拉德是我遇到的最好的证人之一。他的证词对他的伤害极大。”裁决宣布后，塔米的家人发表了一份声明，上面写道：“正义终于得以伸张，所有的谎言都可以停止了。塔米是一个如此美好、对生活充满热情的人。不幸的是，她没有机会为自己和海莉创造更好的生活。”
Despite the mandatory life sentence for first-degree murder, an official sentencing date was set so that Tammy's loved ones could have their moment to speak about the impact the murder had on their lives. Hailey chose not to speak, instead providing the judge with an undisclosed written statement. As Tammy's mother Bonnie addressed the courtroom, Brad Rhea stood with his eyes glued to the floor. Bonnie said, We trusted you for so many years and you deceived us. You have taken all that you can from this family. On this earth, you will not receive enough punishment for your heinous crime.
尽管一级谋杀罪面临强制性的终身监禁，法庭还是正式设定了一个宣判日期，以便塔米的亲人们有机会就这起谋杀对他们生活的冲击发表感言。海莉选择不发言，而是向法官提交了一份未公开的书面声明。当塔米的母亲邦尼走向法庭发言时，布拉德·雷亚双眼死死盯着地板。邦尼说：“我们信任了你这么多年，你却欺骗了我们。你已经从这个家庭夺走了你所能夺走的一切。在这个大地上，你所受到的惩罚永远无法弥补你那残忍的罪行。”
She added that Brad should be ashamed of himself for trying to blame his own daughter, quipping, I'm surprised you didn't try to blame the cat. A video slideshow celebrating Tammy's life was played, but Brad showed zero emotion. At no point did he apologize. He seemed intent on sticking to his story that Hailey was the real killer, telling the court, I gave up my life because I love her. The judge concluded that Brad was a calculated, cold-blooded murderer, motivated to kill Tammy out of revenge for her having an affair and wanting a divorce.
她补充说，布拉德试图将罪责推给自己的亲生女儿，这让他感到极其羞耻，并讽刺道：“我很惊讶你居然没有试图把罪名推给那只猫。”法庭播放了一个庆祝塔米一生的视频幻灯片，但布拉德毫无情绪波动。他自始至终没有道歉。他似乎铁了心要坚持“海莉才是真正的凶手”这一谎言，对法庭说：“我放弃了我的人生，因为我爱她。”法官总结指出，布拉德是一个蓄谋已久、冷血的凶手，杀害塔米的动机是为了报复她出轨并执意要离婚。
She told Brad he had unsuccessfully attempted to paint himself as the victim. Quote, You are not a victim, you are a predator. Along with a life sentence, the judge ordered that Brad be forbidden from having contact with Hailey or Tammy's family ever again. Brad tried to appeal the conviction and called for a retrial. He argued that Hailey's DNA was never compared to DNA found at the crime scene, and that his defense lawyer had failed him by not pursuing any other DNA evidence. He also claimed that investigators had falsified evidence against him.
她告诉布拉德，他试图把自己粉饰成受害者的企图以失败告终。“引用：你不是受害者，你是一个掠夺者。”除了判处终身监禁外，法官还下令禁止布拉德再与海莉或塔米的家人有任何接触。布拉德试图对定罪提出上诉并要求重审。他辩称，海莉的DNA从未与案发现场的DNA进行过比对，并且他的辩护律师没有追求任何其他DNA证据，这辜负了他。他还声称调查人员伪造了对不利于他的证据。
His appeal was unanimously rejected. Hailey Rhea lost both parents on the day her father made the decision to murder her mother. She went to live with Tammy's family in Wyoming and never saw Brad again. In the wake of the crime, Tammy's sister Holly told NBC reporter Josh Mankiewicz, Quote, The best you can do is try to stay strong forever. Quote, The best you can do is try to stay strong for Hailey.
他的上诉被一致驳回。海莉·雷亚在父亲做出谋杀母亲决定的那一天，失去了双亲。她搬去怀俄明州与塔米的家人同住，再也没有见过布拉德。在这场悲剧之后，塔米的姐姐霍利对全国广播公司（NBC）记者乔希·曼基维茨说：“引用：你能做的最好的事情，就是努力永远保持坚强。”“引用：你能做的最好的事情，就是为了海莉努力坚强下去。”
It's really like having someone cut your arm off. I mean, it's a piece of you that you never get back. And thank goodness we still have Hailey, because she is so much like her mum. Tammy's family successfully filed a wrongful death lawsuit against Brad for $5.3 million, while Brad didn't have that much money. The ruling allowed them to sell off his personal property and give the proceeds to Hailey. Growing up without Tammy was incredibly difficult for Hailey, but she refused to let the tragedy define her.
这真的就像有人砍掉了你的一条胳膊。我的意思是，那是你永远无法找回的一部分自己。谢天谢地，我们身边还有海莉，因为她和她的妈妈太像了。”塔米的家人成功对布拉德提起了非法致死民事诉讼，索赔530万美元，尽管布拉德并没有那么多钱。这一裁决允许他们变卖他的个人财产，并将所得款项交给海莉。在没有塔米陪伴的情况下长大对海莉来说极其艰难，但她拒绝让这场悲剧定义自己。
After graduating high school, she studied criminal justice at university before getting married and having a son of her own. The unconditional love her mother gave her has been an ongoing motivator for Hailey, who continues to look up to Tammy and aspire to be the type of parent she was. Looking back, Hailey now realizes that just because her father wasn't physically violent, it doesn't mean he wasn't abusing Tammy in other ways. Brad was known to constantly hover over Tammy, often not letting her out of his sight.
高中毕业后，她在大学学习了刑事司法，随后结婚并生下了自己的儿子。母亲给予她的无条件爱一直是海莉不断前行的动力，她始终敬仰塔米，并渴望成为像她那样优秀的父母。回首往事，海莉现在意识到，仅仅因为她的父亲没有进行身体上的暴力，并不意味着他没有以其他方式虐待塔米。众所周知，布拉德经常在塔米身边阴魂不散，常常不让她离开自己的视线范围。
His controlling behavior bordered on obsessive. When he wasn't at work, he'd often show up unannounced wherever Tammy was. When the couple would visit Tammy's family in Wyoming, Tammy's sisters and mother noticed that Brad would sit so close to Tammy that no one else could come near her. While Brad had sulked and barely ate for days after the couple told Hailey they were getting divorced, Tammy had appeared unaffected. It was as though her weight had finally been lifted.
他这种控制欲近乎偏执。当他不在工作时，经常会不请自来到塔米所在的任何地方。当这对夫妇去怀俄明州探望塔米的家人时，塔米的姐妹和母亲注意到布拉德总是紧挨着塔米坐，不让任何人靠近她。当这对夫妇告诉海莉他们要离婚后，布拉德生闷气且好几天几乎吃不下饭，而塔米则显得毫不在意。这就好像她心中的一块巨石终于落地了一样。
Wanting to make sure her mother didn't lose her life in vain, Hailey has used her experience to educate others on the early warning signs of domestic violence. She has worked with various charities and organizations, traveling the United States to speak about victims' rights and the red flags to look out for. Hailey shares her journey on a Facebook page titled, In Memory of Tammy Burns-Rhea. In a 2016 TED Talk, Hailey said, Hailey said,
为了确保母亲没有白白牺牲，海莉用自己的亲身经历教育他人警惕家庭暴力的早期预警信号。她与各种慈善机构和组织合作，走遍美国各地，宣讲受害者权益以及需要留意的危险信号。海莉在名为“纪念塔米·伯恩斯·雷亚”（In Memory of Tammy Burns-Rhea）的Facebook页面上分享她的心路历程。在2016年的一场TED演讲中，海莉说道，海莉说道：
However, what I can do is be her voice. I will speak out for her and so many others who did not get the chance. Just because my mum didn't have physical scars that everyone could see, she had emotional scars, ones that never go away. Not every situation has to end the way ours did, but I will continue to be my mum's voice, because silence will not break the violence. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然而，我能做的是成为她的声音。我要为她以及许多其他没有机会发声的人大声疾呼。虽然我妈妈身上没有每个人都能看到的身体伤疤，但她有着永远不会消失的情感伤疤。并不是每个情况都必须以我们这样的结局收场，但我会继续做我妈妈的声音，因为沉默无法打破暴力。目前这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。